whoa hey there welcome back to new
rockstars I'm your host Sam basher and
let's break down the new trailer for
season two of Jessica Jones returning
March 8th 2018 hoo boy I'm excited I was
a big fan of season 1 and cannot wait
for more Jessica Jones cursing at
strangers on the street and day drinking
hooray
my favorite superheroes do that kids
don't do that that's a bad lesson I
learned here is that no one's ever
allowed to be happy in the Marvel
Netflix shows maybe Luke Cage but barely
let's go Easter egg hunting shall we you
know the drill spoiler warning for
Jessica Jones season once the other
Marvel Netflix shows season 2 of Jessica
Jones Jessica Jones comics excetera
let's get going roll the clip third
glass tonight put it on my tab you
drinking to remember forget giving a
[ __ ] won't get you a better tip what a
depressing intro so Jessica is not doing
so hot after the events of the defenders
season 1 she's drinking herself silly
not in a fun way though in a dangerous
way but we are finally getting more
clips of what I assumed to be the death
of Jessica's family specifically her
mother father and younger brother that's
her whole family I didn't know if you
knew that that's very sad it's very
tragic nothing too much to glean from
this but still all these clips will be
important later on let's keep going oh
[Music]
my whole family was killed in the kayaks
someone did horrific experiments on me
you know this super vigilante [ __ ] keeps
coming at me
do you know Captain America
now in these clips we actually find out
what happened to Jessica or get a better
idea of what happened following the
events of her family's deaths now in the
comics and from what I've gathered from
the first season of the show there was a
car accident some chemicals may have
come into contact with her kind of
daredevil ish a little bit she gets
powers and then BOOM now in the first
season we find out that she moves in
with Trish and her mom it's easy-peasy
makes sense however it now looks like
she was experimented on falling in the
crash and then she was able to escape
maybe or possibly she was allowed to
escape and she's been monitored ever
since cut this girl some slack please
she is not doing well also on top of all
of this we now know she's being
recognized for killing kilgrave or
possibly even stopping the hand from
taking up those dragon bones and sink in
New York into the defenders I just say
that out loud and still doesn't make any
sense
anyhoo this leads to an awesome nod to
the larger MCU this kid asks if she
knows Captain America how adorable
based on timelines though cap might be
charged with treason for not signing the
serkova accords you know along with Iron
Man team captain Miami you remember
let's just pretend that he's still a
Captain America it makes sense he'll
still be able to keep all of his toys
without feeling that this isn't the
first time Captain America has been
mentioned with his full title Luke Cage
has even referred to as Harlem's Captain
America but it is always fun but maybe
that means cap will will go recruit
Jessica Jones for his underground
freedom fighter Avengers you know cuz he
ran away at the end of Civil War what's
he been doing between then and infinity
or maybe who knows also it's worth
mentioning the father of this kid is
played by JR Ramirez and he should have
a pretty prominent role in this season
of Jessica Jones they actually pops up a
couple more times in this trailer I
believe so keep your peepers peeled you
could even maybe become one of Jessica's
love interest possibly who knows I know
Luke's over with Claire and Harlem they
can't get together which is always gonna
be a bummer also I'm just so glad we
have Trish back I miss her every day of
my life she's amazing also also we get
this awesome shot that slides through
the digital camera little viewfinder to
capture some photos of some perps who
could they be soon young ones next clip
absorb alias investigations you don't
want me you just want to eliminate the
competition I never take no for an
answer
how rapey of you something happened
behind these doors I have 17 years of
questions and they are deep now this
clip of a point-of-view moving through
the viewfinder of the camera to spy on
those two guys and the clip of Jessica
sitting and drinking on the edge of the
building seem to be connected in some
way you know seems like the same place
look at the building in the background
look at the building they're in make
sense hooray
awesome hooray day drinking on the side
of a building do not do that that's
super dangerous don't forget those guys
were spying on because we see one of
those guys in the next scene saying he
wants to buy out alias investigations
that's Jessica Jones company if you
happen to forget also fun fact alias is
both the name of the P I office the
Jessica Jones owns and the name of the
Jessica Jones debut comic Ramar Vil
alias also has been said by a couple of
the creative people behind the show that
there will be multiple villains this
season so based on just spying on him
and him trying to buy up her business he
will probably be a villain some sort of
PR who's come bad maybe also gay
Malcolm's back mr. to but also also yeh
we know now that her mother's name is
Alyssa Jones based on that certificate
on the wall next clip just knowing what
was done to you might help you we were
made here
me and something else the only way to
find it is to open the door wider so
it's much clearer from the first trailer
to this one what this season will be
about finding out who jessica is and
what turned her into a superhero and it
looks like Trish Walker bestest of
friends is here to help in more ways
than one
also please pay attention to we were
made here that line jessica goes on to
say that she and something else were
created in this secret lab possibly the
lab is hidden within this theater this
dirty theater that they're walking
around in I'm guessing but it was hinted
to at the end of season 1 that IG age a
paramilitary group they gave nuke his
pills that made him super crazy and
crazy strong had something to do with
the chemicals that gave Jess her powers
so maybe this line here is actually cut
together from two different
conversations to make you know a very
enticing little sound bite for this
trailer who knows what I'm saying is
sure maybe there's just one thread out
there that has Jessica's powers and is
running around killing people hurting
people but what if nuke makes it return
this season and there are some more
soldiers just like him it's an opinion
now let's check out this shot here
notice the attackers hair we see another
glimpse of this person later on so
remember that along early hair next clip
[Music]
our side effect
how many others are there like me let it
go there is a killer you cannot control
I didn't ask for any of this so just got
made it back to her hellish origins and
we see some sort of device that was used
during her resurrection it's got a big
arm and now here's this fun little twist
like I said previously she was in a coma
and then woke up with powers there's
nothing about her dying in the comics as
a fun little twist that this show came
up with this show has taken some
liberties and telling us something new
how fun next let's focus on these
metallic cubes right here on her thigh
now first you'd probably think badness
how do they work deep cut internet joke
anyways but I think it has to do with
her ability specifically her enhanced
strength
check out those marks left on her right
thigh it looks like these cubes are
injecting something into Jessica could
this have to do with her abilities or
are the scientists just slowly
regenerating parts of her body until
she's fully resurrected that seems
tedious but hey I've never resurrected
anybody successfully we then meet Janet
tears character who is yet to be named
but has been described as having a very
big hand in Jessica's past possibly one
of the scientists that worked on her
maybe has some to do with kilgrave maybe
or here's the crazy fan theory part
maybe this is Alyssa Jones Jessica's mom
Alyssa alias and a changeable last
letters maybe it's a hint that Alyssa
might still be alive if she knows an
awful lot about Jessica maybe I'm on to
something here but anyway there's a hint
two possibly more super-powered people
out there where could they be
we then see Jessica jumping off a ferris
wheel which is actually something we've
seen before I didn't point this out the
first time around back it up just a
little bit to the photo of Jess and her
dead brother BAM ferris wheel right back
there exact same one looks exactly the
same maybe some of her family is alive
after all or the villain knows about
this it's just toying with her again
people can't be happy on these shows
next we see a bloody dead man in the
back of a white van no leads on the
identity but he does come up again soon
stay tuned remember all these details
but also celebrate sense Hogarth is back
as well
yay I love this cast we also see another
dead body and some wreckage and Jessica
is very up
is the anti Jessica going around killing
people for no reason do they mean
something to her think about it while we
roll the next clip Jessica might not
want a sidekick but she's keep telling
me who I am I'll tell you what if AC
makes me worse now here we see Jessica
is somewhere on a beach with Trish Trish
comforting her possibly after a big
revelation about her past everyone likes
to go to the beach to contemplate things
maybe she's got purple man nightmares
oops
I'm getting ahead of myself the next
clip is of a man attacking Trish
he looks somewhat familiar don't he well
if he looked up the IMDB of jr. Ramirez
he would look familiar it's kind of
blurry I know but if you freeze frame
and you focus kind of hard it does look
a lot like Oscar jr. mears's character
who is the father that we mentioned
earlier
could he be whammied by purple man or
popper man's ghost or maybe he's another
villain there are a lot of options here
but Trish can handle herself listen to
this audio Jessica might not want a
psychic but she needs one I'm thinking
this season will finally be the time for
Trish to become her superhero persona
Hellcat I mean come on wouldn't it be
awesome it's for good health Kat she's
awesome
now Hellcat if you don't know is a
street-level hero with martial arts
training and some retractable claws
because the cat part of her name
sometimes she's got psychic senses which
could possibly happen in this world
maybe she gets some of the stuff they
gave Jess her powers or gay purple man
his powers and that gives her powers but
truth be told I don't need them she's
great as is the next shot we get is
Jessica staring at a glass of some
alcohol possibly whiskey probably and it
looks like she could maybe think about
giving it all up but try to tackle her
alcoholism in this season it would be a
compelling story and it could maybe lead
to her and Luke getting back together
maybe she cleans up her act a little bit
maybe she's a little happier we didn't
see Jessica chasing down genic mcteer's
character in the same bar we saw before
where they were talking and she gives
her a quick punch and knocks her out
into that glass on the window it breaks
it's a pretty brutal
do we think mcteer's character is in on
all this villainy this season most
likely but can she take that kind of
punch
we'll have to see I don't think Jessica
would straight-up killer right there
unless she's super duper duper duper
evil but maybe McTeer can
take it maybe she's enhanced we then see
Jessica face off against the pie that we
saw earlier who probably has just
crossed Jessica because she looks pissed
I like this guy's look though so I'm
interested to see what the writers do
with his character finally in this clip
we see Jessica in what looks to be a
prison of sorts maybe a locked room my
guess is that she's gonna get captured
at least once during this season all
superheroes do every once in a while but
hey mm-hmm just captured her next clip
you didn't do I don't know depends on if
I can get through this night without
losing my [ __ ]
[Music]
it takes a monster
to stop the monster
things are starting to ramp up quick now
let's focus on this clip first looks to
be dirt and ash raining down on Jessica
slowly we did see an explosion earlier
in the trailer so this could be the ash
from that building burning or possibly
this could be part of her PTSD from
kilgrave and the death of her family
next we get someone in an office being
thrown through a glass door and based on
the outfit it looks like our PI friend
from earlier so we should expect some
hand-to-hand combat between this P I and
Jessica it's at least a few times in
this season hopefully we then get a
glimpse of Jessica being detained by
police officers on the street which
seems to be the same place that she and
Malcolm were when they found the dead
body in the back of that white van all
the white vans coming up again don't
worry it's gonna come up one more time
in this video stay tuned but the
question is why is riska being arrested
is it because there's evidence at the
crime scene that points to Jessica maybe
the powers that the killer had are
similar to Jess we then see a pretty
messed up skull that is promptly dropped
by Jess and then she and Trish freaked
out my two guesses this is another
person experimented on just like Jess or
possibly a paramilitary volunteer for
IgH that needed to disappear it's dark
but maybe we then see Hogarth weeping
possibly over Jessica or maybe someone
broke her heart
who knows possibly heartbreak though
because later we see our slow dancing
with a pretty lady and no one can be
happy here but anyways a cool part that
followed this scene that got me really
excited looks to be a jailbreak from a
hospital or possibly the facility that
brought Jess back to life most likely
the latter next we see just looking to
be shaking down a gangster but I might
be prejudiced just because that gold
James you know the open collar right
there but if this is true this doesn't
mean that we'll be getting some scenes
or episodes dedicated to Jess just being
a full-blown pi which I am in too but
here's a question who is chasing Malcolm
down the street I guess someone who was
a part of the group who gave Jess her
powers or maybe Malcolm tried to go out
on his own and things got a heavy think
about who that could be and on top of
that think about how this woman with the
curly hair attacking this man with the
outdated Bluetooth looks to have the
same hair as the woman who attacked
Jessica in that church earlier hmm and
that man looks to be wearing the same
clothes as the torn apart body we saw in
the back of the white van from earlier
as well oh it's even the same they
or there's a lot of white vans in this
universe so close to the end we see
Trish holding a gun to someone who could
that be who could be scaring her so much
we then see Jess about to do the deed in
some paint could that be Oscar the
father from earlier the last thing we
see before we cut to black is just
running towards an explosion now either
this is a real time event or this could
be a flashback or a nightmare of the day
that she lost her family either way I
think she'll make it but I kind of hope
this season will help define her powers
a little bit better final clip please
what did they do to us
speaking of needed answers how in the
heck is killgrave alive what a haunting
way to introduce him in this trailer I
really loved it though so patronizing
and we barely saw him now here's the
question
is he alive now in the comics the purple
man does have a healing factor of sorts
so he could have faked his death or just
healed up from it over time or
alternatively and this could be more
interesting this is just as PTSD or
inner demons manifesting but those are
my theories what do you guys think what
are you most excited about for season 2
of Jessica Jones let me know in the
comments down below or on twitter at
only stupid answers yank out those
vowels from stupid be sure to LIKE share
and subscribe to new rockstars for more
breakdowns I'm Sam basher and I'll see
it next time